Eric chernak in the corner pumps it up along the
wall Puck battle at Center cro there gets it to
Braden point he'll dish for Hegel Hegel delivers
cro score on Q redot COV makes it one nothing
Tampa wow his knee surgery in St Louis
on Saturday up by Nick Paul in the corner
works it up for chernack Victor headman wrist
shot knocked out in traffic a rebound Paul and
Allen got a piece and dorak trying to clear
and he will clear it out of the front of the
net counter Sherry going off slowly after get
hit in front of the net with that puck there's
new HW delivers in front Anderson looking for the
tip and his skates as Suzuki recovers that battle
continues in the corner freeze it for Monahan
with Anderson Monahan in front for Anderson just
out of his reach half to in deep cutting to the
net mat Around the Net in front G field off the
post I'm just curious going back to
back here John Cooper is getting very
creative with his line changes and lines
coov is with Sherry out Stam coast and
C are getting tons of ice new hook at
the line tried to poke it away from cro
he protects so across for headman down
low stamp go shoots rebound score Paul
off the rebound and he buries it two
nothing Tampa here at the Bell Center
and again here's COV making the play going side to
side but there's two Tampa forwards down low only
one defenseman in mat Suzuki who has to retreat
back down to the front of the net when the plays
made at the Blue Line and Matson get stuck trying
to play this and I guess the option is St Co good
read by Allen and a good save 196 career Power
Play Goals for St goes that shot call and it's
the Quebec kid getting it on Alex B Boule his
first game in Montreal his first goal at the Bell
Center as starts the faceof Win Second unit
out here but they work the scam and that hits
either mat skate or Jano stick or maybe a bit
of both no didn't get to finish the story but
his parents they bought tickets the last time
then he was set down as asot got some space
asot shoots off the post man Tamp is coming Harris
takes contact from Jano works it in as xano leads
the tapa Bay lightning in hits this season Mikey
asimon chips to himself at the line asimon on the
puck brings it in shoots try to tuck it in short
side it's in and it's in it's in asot knew right
away Allan thought he had it and it's four nothing
Tampa in the first under 14 minutes another tough
play mat's having a tough first period he plays
the park fly by and acon gets a little Angle now
this should never go in of course Jake Allen gets
caught cheating off the post but another innocent
looking rush and asima who was a scratch last
night's game against Toronto responds to being
put back in the lineup by putting one in the back
of the net Co Coffield try to slash the backend
in Glen Denning knocked it down but Coffield
gets it back Zips it across Suzuki for Circle
Suzuki track move backhand try follow up that
didn't get through as Anderson trying to cat his
first petta below the goal line for kovich he'll
play it off the wall Jacky ban on it cro able to
steal in front stab Coast quick shot what a
stop montmo Cheno oh big hit Cheno on Sosi as
he hammered him into the board it's a Tampa look
out aont Breakaway he's in he's shoot mampo shut
him down was coming had no problem with that
he was one of the league leaders in fights a
couple years ago in Nashville there's the big hit
puck gets turn over and asimon gets sent in alone
looking for a second tied for third in NHL scoring
second in NHL assists and just off to a red hot
start this year as well he'll bring it in what a
move COV the feed back at try Oho ra points who's
who's not sure should he just shoot the [__]
right in the open side or should he take it back
across but start the coocher off see you later 1
two three and oh mono just leaves the leg there
Point chernak walks it in drops it off B cross
I spe step Co ripped it off the
crossbar what a feed and what a
shot chips around cir CHF goes into the corner
there's Dean lovsky engag AES up top for Barett
bar Point Barett across new Hook New hook pearon
towards the net to the forehead that's try and a
good stop there as sovi nearly had one gallager
kicked aside in front parison what a stop Matt
Tomkins his best work of the night made two passes
and got some great opportunities and Tomkins does
not move well when he's down on the ground he
sort of gets stuck roaming around Pearson just
over skates one opportunity that can't quite
Corral the second one quick enough Tomkins
is fighting yeah Sosi almost got the first one
there but that's better stuff in mat Bru Center
R left side for Monahan Monahan centering pass
up top Suzuki one time score finally they break
through Nick Suzuki power play goal and the
hals got one by Tomkins [Applause] although
the coaching staff was checking this for offside
so we'll see that's a excellent pass from man and
he go see on the tape they go right back against
it when you get the puck going laterally on the
tape with your skill players good things are
going to happen Tampa always over pursues on
the entry they try to flood the zone and monan
able to Rel pressure and you know he's only had
18 shots again petta wind upop and that one stung
Jeff he's limping around the ice shots and crash
Gully rer tipped in front Evans loose score
Michael petta with your spark Montreal with it
two what a time for his first of the year petta
4-2 game shots and crash you were asking for
well here it is Evans petta banging away play
physical down low serach had gotten knocked
over the corner and a nice little tip from Evans
and possett and they do this with point on the
ice as well backing up a power play goal here's
headman COV works it down low gets it back coov
feeds the point headman delivers Point looking
for that tip point in front what a stop Point
plank B him B on Braden point at a two-on one
zachf goes down low pass for Bar B WR shot and
handled as the Great Stop mono on his former
Junior teammate COV backand intended for Point
headman back to COV space in front R shot just
wide oh what a look by Paul it wasn't for him
that pass was so hard that was forced to be
for stos stos who drop one timer what a stop
rebound score great stop montmo but cutting in
was Paul for his second of the game and there's
your insurance 5-2 Tampa he look in in in the slot
but but the first one comes snapping through and
he takes it this one goes back through to utov
who's making a living over that onetime really
good save from monmo but Nick Paul is really
good awareness by Paul radish there first Baron
on the puck for [Applause] Harris Harris dorak
in stride Christian dorak Rich shot store as
dorak buries one a late tonight and that's his
first goal since February 28th at San Jose he'll
take it 8 seconds left can he do it again Dvorak
tried the centering pass has control that shot
blocks trying to get one more by but the horns
sounds and what a special night for Matt topkins